we're going to do things slightly
differently today and I'm going to go
through the charts I'm joined by
Professor John Newton from the test and
trace program and will then answer
questions from the public and from
journalists and if there's one message
that we have today it's that it is
incredibly important for anybody who has
symptoms of coronavirus a cough or a
fever or a change in your sense of taste
or smell that you get a test because
it's by people coming forward to get the
test which you can get on NHS you have
UK forward slash coronavirus or by
dialing 1 1 9 it's by getting those
tests that were able to identify those
who've got the virus ensuring that you
get the best possible treatment and
ensuring that we can then trace the
virus and that we can through that we
can control the virus so that is the
most important message and what
everybody can do to help to control this
virus if we turn now to the slides the
first slide shows testing capacity and
new cases and yesterday there were a
hundred and twenty eight thousand four
hundred and thirty seven tests in the UK
meaning that there's been a total of
four point four eight million tests that
have been carried out since the start of
this crisis
now of course testing capacity stands at
a higher level testing capacity stands
at two hundred and six thousand four
hundred and forty four and this shows
that there is extra capacity for more
tests and tests are available right now
on the website if you go to NHS UK
forward slash coronavirus or if you
can't access the web if you dial one one
nine and I wanted to highlight that
because it's so important that people
come forward for a test and anyone who
needs
test can get a test the next if we say
at the previous slide the next chart
that shows that there are 1570 cases
confirmed as of yesterday and this is
the lowest number since the 25th of
March in total two hundred and seventy
six thousand people cases have been
confirmed in total but this number of
1570 is it shows that we've seen
continued downward progress in the
number of new confirmed cases
next slide please thank you very much
we're getting this virus under control
and this is why we can make the cautious
small positive steps that we've been
able to make today and if we look at the
number of Admissions we've covered
nineteen to hospital at four hundred and
seventy nine that's down from a peak of
3121 on the second of April and the
number of the proportion of people on
mechanical ventilators the number that
corresponds to that nine percent figure
is that there are six hundred and six
people on mechanical ventilators again
that is the lowest since late March next
like these the picture is repeated
across the country where we've seen in
almost every case the number of people
in hospital we've covered nineteen is
the lowest since late March and as of
yesterday there were seven thousand five
hundred and forty-one people in hospital
with Kovac nineteen if we go to our
final slide sadly thirty nine thousand
and forty five people have died with
corona virus confirmed with a positive
test that's a hundred and eleven
yesterday again that figure is the
lowest figure since lockdown began on
the 23rd of March so we can see for
on these charts the pattern right across
the board which is that on the substance
we're making significant progress but
there is still more to be done and I
just want to say a few notes of thanks
thanks to our volunteers responders who
in their hundreds of thousands have come
forward and stepped up to the plate
thanks to the charities and the charity
groups who are working so hard in very
difficult times
thanks to colleagues in the NHS and into
social care and also to the businesses
the pharmaceutical companies and the
diagnostics companies without whom we
simply couldn't have mounted this
response to the pharmacists and the
dentists and I'm very pleased that
Dentistry is going to restart from next
week and especially for their hard work
and their understanding all of the
families who stand behind those who were
on the frontline and at the start of
Pride season I want to take a moment
when we can't get together as we
normally would to thank all colleagues
in the LGBT community who do so much in
the NHS and across social care I think
these data show that the action plan is
working the data show that we are
winning the battle against coronavirus
today we're therefore able to make some
cautious changes to the lockdown rules
carefully and safely of course these are
balanced judgments and we take these
decisions very carefully we must all
remember that in the war against this
virus we are all on the same side we've
come so far together we can take these
steps together but do not step too far
the disease is not done yet we mustn't
throw away the progress that has been
made so please take your responsibility
seriously if you have symptoms you must
get a test and if the NHS asks you to
isolate you must do so and to everybody
please stay alert control the virus and
save lives